our Game of Thrones finally landed in
Seville to show dragonpit scenes in
Metallica more than a dozen cast members
showed up and the list is quite
interesting and surprising without any
confirmation of the contrary if we are
to assume that every cast member that
landing in Seville will shoot this
swimming will include 19 main characters
the dragon pit scenes would include the
entire start family just snow Branson
Santeria all the Lannisters Tyrion Jaime
and Cersei only one Greyjoy Yara
most of the nice team very sure moment
great one bath without Danny herself
that was Seaworth be enough darts entire
league injury Robin Arryn and the final
three that make this list both shocking
and surprising the night King Jackie hug
are in the way there are also few
absences that are perhaps even more
intriguing especially given that many of
their companions are there then his
entire team is there except from Sandy
also even though searched his presence
she's alone her most trusted people
Qyburn and the mountain are not there
nor is her only Ally your own rager
characters like for example theme
Greyjoy torment Bronn Podrick and many
more are also not there taking into
account that these dragon pit scenes
served by many sources a stone to take
place in the final season's finale it
could mean that some of these characters
may be dead at this point a few days ago
Emily or Clarke connectors that purchase
Danny said that the ending of Game of
Thrones will be what none of us think it
will be and the presence of the night
king with the entire living side a
dragon pit does ring some bells the
Great War a war between the living and
that there is what the entire series has
been leading to from the very first
scene we've learned that eventually it
will all come to the point where the
politics worse among the kings queens
and Lords will be ended by approaching
army of the Dead enter leader the night
king season 7 finale left us with the
army of the Dead the greatest threat
Westeros has ever seen marching south
after breaching the wall obviously we're
all expecting the great for numerous
epic scenes with John at the very end
defeating the night king but they must
consider the ending that none of us
expect in my opinion that's a pact
between the living and the dead a pact
of Ice and Fire
there will be the great for raging
investors for the most of the final
season but eventually upon both sides
have taken many casualties the living
and the dead will make a pact the most
popular fan theory regarding the Game of
Thrones ending would definitely be Denny
sacrifice and death in order to end the
long night and her absence from this
meeting will definitely make this theory
more fans both the John and Danny are
tied to the other high prophecy which
includes a historic legend of a hero
sacrificing his love in order to save
the world for
night melisandre already told the nurse
that she has her role to play in the
prophecies - Jon Snow the nurse's role
in the long night but this theory will
be her taking a sword into her heart as
the sacrifice required to win the Great
War however while this theory would most
certainly match with George our Mars
announced bittersweet ending the night's
king presence on the dragon pit meeting
does seem to indicate that this theory
is not likely to come true I still
believe that a theory of mine will come
true is the nares becoming the night's
queen the night screen is an unseen
woman in Game of Thrones so legendary
figure known in the Seven Kingdoms and
among the free folk according to legend
the Lord Commander of the Nights Watch
found in haunted forest a cold woman
with bright blue eyes he took her to the
other side of the wall and declared
himself as the night's king earlier in
Game of Thrones have learned that the
leader of the White Walkers the night
King is able to create other White
Walkers but it seems that he can only
create one if that human being is a
pure-blooded incest borne this means
that the night's king could return the
nearest Inn to one of them since then is
a pure-blooded incest born daughter of
King Aerys and Queen rhaella Targaryen
the only way for the living side to end
the long night is Twitter defeat them
which would be insanely hard or to make
a pact which would indeed explain the
night Kings presence on the dragon pit
meeting with a leader subtle inside
respect of Ice and Fire would include an
ears have you ever wondered why is the
night king even coming south why was he
preparing an army all those years with
which he started marching south at the
moment of the nurses arrival at Westeros
I was wondering about that ever since
the sixth season ended and I came to a
conclusion that the nurses rival at
Westeros is the reason of the night
Kings preparations the reason of his
march south and his reason of every
single death that the Seven Kingdoms is
going to confront Dany could have on the
throne as soon as she arrived at
Westeros if she had wanted to as yon
stated then he hasn't taken the throne
yet only because many innocent people
would have died if she had decided to
storm the King's Landing
she didn't attacking slain him because
she didn't want to cause death upon
millions of innocent people and she will
not ever sit on the Iron Throne because
she will decide to give up her life's
all those people including her child
could live then he will accept a pact
with a knight king in order to end long
night she'll become the night's queen
whereupon she and the knight king will
go beyond the wall and rule over it as a
form of peace agreement between the
living and the dead
then his rival at Westeros in the 19th
preparations and his march to the south
fits perfectly in timeline I don't think
it's coincidence that all those years
and that King was preparing and
gathering huge army with which he
started marching south at the same time
of danger
arrival at Westeros also the fact that
the show included multiple scenes are
proving that night king can create
either White Walkers only that human
being is pure blooded and says born has
to be foreshadowing something huge add
to that the fact that Daenerys is incest
born daughter of King Aerys and Queen
rhaella Targaryen and this theory has a
huge chance of coming true not only that
this theory would be one of the greatest
surprises that shorteners could pull out
in the final season's finale but it
would also fit perfectly with the
bittersweet ending that george RR martin
announced Denair so in this theory die
in the hands of the night king is the
nearest sandal shortly after open her
eyes as the night's Queen this is the
end almost none of us would see coming
as I already said we all expect the
Great War to end with one winner whether
it's John Denny and the living or the
night King and the army of the Dead what
majority of us don't expect is the great
war to end with a pact with an agreement
between the Westeros a leader in the
night King now let's see other
characters that are shockingly attending
this huge meeting in the dragon pit its
jockey hugger and waif the bigger
surprise here however is the wave she
was an acolyte of the faceless man
serving in the house of black and white
in Braavos until Arya Stark killed her
adding the waves face to the Hall of
faces or at least that's what we think
happened there's quite a popular theory
of the wave actual being victorious in a
fight against arya and actually using
her face this entire time so basically
this theory states that Arya died in the
fight against the wave and the wave has
been varying arias face in portraying
her ever since but let's get a bit back
to see all the hints and clues that
support his theory after Arya survived
multiple stab wounds sleeping on a
window
falling down the stairs and after
apparently managing to defeat wave
already did something even more strange
even though jock indeed state that there
is not a third chance he basically said
that Aria must die or you still felt a
need to say farewell to her mentor which
is strange to say at least as only
logical choice would be to run away from
Braavos as soon as you can especially
when the faceless men are after you as
well no warrior came back to the house
of black and white with a face that is
apparently face of the wave which is
surprising this area could barely stand
not to mention fight and win against the
wave on top of all of those facts re
also seemingly recovered from serious
wounds and blood loss in short amount of
time well some of us would tell that
lady crane was of tremendous help to
Arya might have even healed her in short
amount of time
some of us could also tell that Arya
played it very smart Arion purpose
headed to the dark chamber in a room in
which she had hidden her sword in a room
that had only one source of light a
candle that are a slice that she has
that her chance of surviving is good the
room faded black and the next thing we
see is Jackie and entering the Hall of
faces where he finds out that Tyra
killed the wife upon learning this
Jackie was surprisingly happy about her
reclaiming her identity and her
intentions to go home even though some
of us could tell the Tyrells martyred
and eventually bested the wave there are
some things that are quite strange could
it be that Aria did not survive could it
be that the person that returned to the
house of black and white was the very
very gorgeous face well there's
certainly a possibility the wave just
Azaria had also been training to become
no.1
so perhaps by killing and becoming Aria
she passed her test and became the
faceless man this would explain why the
wave was interested then was in fact
knowing almost every single detail about
arias whole life and about her family
which is something that a faceless man
had to do before they take someone's
face before they become that same person
before they become no one get her old
information about someone's life so they
could portray that person as best as
they can
Aria by proving that she will never be
no one which you prove by hiding her
sword instead of giving in to have with
all the other things associated with her
old life by killing someone without the
manifest God's blessing and finally
purposely failing to assassinate lady
crane magic Inca guard to fulfill his
promise that he gave to the wave mage a
keen to let the wave kill area where all
this being said if the wave actually
killed into chaos face that will explain
jackings farewell words that he said to
Aria who is by this theory actually the
wayfaring arias face he said finally a
girl is no one something that aria
certainly never became finally a girl is
no one
a girl is aya Stark of Winterfell and
I'm going home
Jacobean brow jacking saying that a girl
has finally became no one might be
referred to the wave as she has also
been trying to prove that she can be
no.1 and maybe by not just killing her
area but also wearing her his face and
becoming arya is the ultimate proof that
she finally became one also we should
consider jack and smile upon our
statement i'm quoting a girl is Arya
Stark of Winterfell and I'm going home
which is something to think about if the
theory is true if are actually is dead
and if the wave is varying her face
Jackie now has a reliable member of the
faceless man masquerading as Arya Stark
which has worked a great deal to the
many-faced God the showrunners might
have left out the battle between the
waif and Arya so they could pull on the
greatest if not the greatest twist in
the final season which once again
provide those of sharks something that
made this show special among all the
others in conclusion the latest looming
news do come as a huge surprise with
night king jacking and very being
together with all other main characters
at the dragon pit meeting and the desert
feeling some intriguing theories